in the last video we were given a
multivariable function and asked to find
and classify all of its critical points
so critical points just means finding
where the gradient is equal to zero and
we found four different points for that
i have them down here they were 0 0 0
negative 2 square root of 3 and 1 and
negative square root of 3 and 1.
so then
the next step is to classify those and
that requires the second partial
derivative test so what i'm going to go
ahead and do is a copy down the partial
derivatives since we already computed
those
copy
and then just kind of paste them down
here
where we can start to
use them for the second partial
derivatives
so
let me clean things up a little bit and
we don't need don't need this
simplification of it
so we've got our partial derivatives now
since we know we want to apply the
second partial derivative test uh we've
got to first just compute all of the
different second partial derivatives of
our function that's just kind of the
first thing to do so let's go ahead and
do it the second partial derivative of
the function with respect to x twice in
a row we'll take
the partial derivative with respect to x
and then do it with respect to x again
so this first term looks like six times
a variable times a constant so it'll
just be six times that constant
and then the second term the derivative
of negative six x is just negative six
moving right along when we do the second
partial derivative with respect to y
twice in a row
we take the partial derivative with
respect to y and then do it again so
this x squared term looks like nothing
looks like a constant as far as y is
concerned so we ignore it the derivative
of negative 3y squared is negative 6
times y
and then the derivative of negative 6y
is just negative 6. and then we can't
forget that last crucially important
mixed partial derivative term
which is the partial derivative of f
where first we do it with respect to x
and then with respect to y the order
doesn't really matter in this case since
it's a perfectly ordinary polynomial
function
so we could do it either way but i'm
just going to choose to take a look at
this guy and differentiate it with
respect to y
so the derivative of the first term with
respect to y is 6 x
6 x
and then that second term looks like a
constant with respect to y so that's all
we have
so now what we're going to do is plug in
each of the critical points to the
special second partial derivative test
expression and to remind you of what
that is
that expression is
we take the second partial derivative
with respect to x twice and i'll just
write it with a kind of shorter notation
using subscripts and we multiply that by
the second partial derivative with
respect to x and then we subtract off
subtract off the mixed partial
derivative term
squared so let's go ahead and do that
for each of our points so when we do
this at the point 0 0
0 0
what we end up getting
plugging that into the partial
derivative with respect to x twice 6
times 0 is 0 so there's just negative 6
so that gives us negative six
multiplied by
when we plug it into this partial
derivative with respect to y squared
again that y goes to zero so we're left
with just negative six
and then we subtract off the mixed
partial derivative term which in this
case is zero because when we plug in x
equals zero we get zero so we're
subtracting off zero squared
and that entire thing equals negative
six times negative six is thirty-six
thirty-six
and we'll get to analyzing what it means
that that's positive in just a moment
but let's just kind of get all of them
on the board so we can kind of start
doing this with all of them if we do
this with 0 and negative 2
0 and negative 2
then once we plug in y equals negative 2
to this expression this time i'll write
it out 6 times negative 2 minus 6 so
that's negative 12 minus 6 we'll get
negative 18
negative 18.
then when we plug it into the partial
derivative of f with respect to y
squared
again i'll kind of write it out we have
negative 6 times y is equal to negative
minus 6. so now we have negative six
times negative two so that's positive 12
minus six so that will be a positive six
that we plug in here
and then for the mixed partial
derivative again x is equal to zero so
the mixed partial derivative is just
going to look like zero when we do this
so we're subtracting off 0 squared and
we get negative 18 times 6 and geez
what's 18 times 6. so that's going to be
36 times 3 so that's the same as 90 plus
18 so i think that's 108 negative 108
and the specific sign the specific
magnitude won't matter it's going to be
the sign that's important and this is
this is definitely negative
so now kind of moving right along these
examples can take quite a while
if we plug in square root of 3 1
square root of 3
what we get
now instead of plugging in y equals
negative 2 we're plugging in y equals 1
so that'll be 6 times 1 minus 6 so the
whole thing is just 0.
and then for the partial derivative with
respect to y squared instead of plugging
in negative 2
now we're plugging in y equals 1.
so we have negative 6 times 1 minus 6 so
the whole thing is negative 12. so
negative 12.
and now for the mixed partial derivative
term
which is 6x x is equal to the square
root of 3 so now we're subtracting off
the square root of three
squared
so what that equals is this first part
is just entirely zero and we're
subtracting off three so that's negative
three
and then
we have square root of three uh no no we
don't that's what we just did now we
have negative square root of 3
and this will be very similar because
this first term just had a y and we
plugged in the y so it's also going to
be 0 for totally the same reasons and
same deal over here the value of y
didn't change so that's also going to be
negative 12. it doesn't really matter
because we're multiplying it by a zero
right and then over here now we're
plugging in negative square root of
three
and that's going to have the same square
so again we're just subtracting off 3.
so what does this second partial
derivative test tell us once we express
this term if it's greater than 0 we have
a max or a min
that's what the test tells us
and then if it's less than 0 if it's
less than zero we have a saddle point
so in this case the only term that's
greater than zero
is this first one
this first one and to analyze whether
it's a maximum or a minimum notice that
the partial derivative with respect to x
twice in a row or with respect to y
twice in a row was negative which
indicates a sort of negative concavity
meaning this corresponds to a maximum so
this guy
corresponds to
a local maximum
now all of the other three gave us
negative numbers so all of these other
three give us saddle points
saddle points
so the answer to the question the
original find and classify you know such
and such points
is that we found four different critical
points
oh let's see four different critical
points 0 0 0 negative 2 square root of 3
1 and negative square root of 3 1 and
all of them are saddle points except for
0 0 which is a local maximum and all of
that is something that we can tell
without even looking at the graph of the
function
and with that i will see you next video